[موسيقى]
لا تزال اصدقاء تمرد مجموعه فاجنر تتردد
بقوه في روسيا وخا فانتقال قائد هذه
المجموعه
وقوته الى بيلاروسيا اثار الكثير من
الريبه والتوجس لدى الدول المجاوره
لبيلاروسيا وخاصه ليتوانيا التي تستعد
لاستضافه القمه السنويه للحلف خلال عشره
ايام فقد حذر رئيسها من خطر وجود مقاتلي
فاجنر في بيلاروسيا على امن المنطقه وايده
في ذلك الرئيس الفولندي الذي قال انه من
المهم للغايه تقويه الجبهه الشرقيه للنيتو
فكيف تقيم دول الحلف التطورات الاخيره في
روسيا وتاثيراتها على مجرى الحرب
المتواصله في اوكرانيا وكيف تنظر موسكو
الى خطط الحلف وتعزيز وجوده العسكري على
مقربه من حدودها اهلا بكم في هذه الحلقه
من سيناريوهات
[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم الاحداث الاخيره في روسيا
تؤكد الحاجه لمزيد من اليقظه والاستعداد
لكل سيناريوهات هذا ما قاله رئيس ليتوانيا
وهو لسان حال العديد من المسؤولين في دول
بحر البلطيخ الذين يتحدثون باستمرار عن
ضروره تعزيز الجناح الشرقي للحلف تحسبا
لاي طارئ عن الهواجس والمخاطر الامنيه
التي يثيرها انتقال مجموعه الى بيلاروسيا
وكيف سيتعامل معها حلف شمال الاطلسي
ومخاوف موسكو ايضا من زحف الحلف اكثر
فاكثر نحو حدودها يسعدنا ان يكون معنا في
هذه الحلقه من بروكليغ من بروكسيل نيكولاس
المستشار السابق لدى حلف في شمال الاطلسي
النيتو من موسكو رونالد بيجاموف الباحث
والمحلل السياسي ومن عمان الدكتور حسن
البراري استاذ العلاقات الدوليه في جامعه
قطر فاهلا بهم جميعا
تداعيته تمرد قائد فاجنر ووصوله الى
بيلاروسيا من المرجح ان تهيمن على جدول
اعمال قمه حلف شمال الاطلسيه المقبله في
العاصمه الليتوانيه
وذلك على بعد مئات الكيلومترات فقط من
القاعده العسكريه الجديده التي قد تؤوي
مقاتل فاجنر في بيلاروسيا ما يثير فزع دول
بحر البلطيق
ويسلط الضوء على الحاجه الملحه لتحصين
الجناح الشرقي للناتو وتعزيز القدرات
العسكريه لاوكرانيا
تدريبات النيتو هذه المسماه
جرت في العاصمه الليتوانيه
من هذا الشهر ليست مجرد جوله تمارين
اعتياديه فللمكان والزمان دلالات مهمه
انها تجريف العاصمه التي تستعد لاحتضان
قمه النيتو في الحادي عشر والثاني عشر من
الشهر المقبل اما زمنيا فقد جاءت بعد
يومين من تمرد فاغنر الذي وضعت داخل
الروسي في دائره الاضواء
تعتقد ليتوانيا انما الت اليه الامور
بانتقال قائد فاجنر الى بيلاروسيا يخلق
لها مصدر تهديد مباشر هذا ما جعل الرئيس
الليتواني جيتا ناسنا حلف شمال الاطلسي
لتعزيز جناحه الشرقي ويقول ان وجود فاجنر
في بيلاروسيا يمثل خطرا اذا مستخدمت
لزعزعه استقرار دول المجاوره
لدى بولندا المخاوف الليتوانيه نفسها في
مؤتمر صحفي بكييف قال الرئيس البولندي
اندريدودا انه لا يستبعد ان يشكل وجود
فاغنرث بيلاروسيا خطرا على بولندا
وليتوانيا هلتين ستبذلان قصار جهدهما
لضمان انضمام اوكرانيا الى النيتو في اسرع
وقت ممكن
بالنسبه
فان انتقال قائد فاجنر الى مينسك لم يكن
سوى اقتراب روسي من الحدود الشرقيه للحلف
في المقابل اكد امنه العام
ان قمه ليتوانيا المقبله ستكون محطه
للاتفاق على خطه تمتد سنوات لدعم اوكرانيا
وان كييف ستوضع على مسار عضويه النيتو
وهذه كانت اسباب روسيا المعلنه قبل ان
تقرر شن الحرب على اوكرانيا
فهواجس من هنا وهواجس من هناك وعادت
الامور الى المربع الاول في خضم حاله
الترقب هذه لا يعرف على وجه التحديد مصير
مؤكد لشركه فاجنر لكن الادوار التي لعبتها
في رعايه المصالح الحيويه لروسيا خارج
الحدود تبقي الحاجه اليها ماسه وقائمه وان
تحت عنوان جديد وبقياده مختلفه
وفق صحيفه وولد جورنال فانها تدر مئات
الملايين من الدولارات سنويا من افريقيا
وهي مصدر تمويل مهم للحفاظ على نفوذ روسيا
في
وللعمليات في اوكرانيا تقول الصحيفه ايضا
ان حوالي سته الاف من فاجنر ينفذون عمليات
خارج روسيا واوكرانيا تشمل حمايه المناجم
والسياسيين في جمهوريه افريقيا الوسطى
والدفاع عن ابار النفط والاراضي التي
تسيطر عليها الحكومه السوريه لذا اكدت
مصادر للصحيفه ان الكريم لن يتجه للسيطره
الكامله على عمليات مجموعه فاغنر في مناطق
انتشارها في العالم
نرحب بضيوفنا من جديد ونبدا من
دول الحلف الاطلسي سيد ويليامز اعربت عن
قلقها مما جرى في روسيا من تداعياته على
امن المنطقه ومن من تداعياته على الحرب في
اوكرانيا ما الذي
يقلقها اكثر
في الواقع ان القلق الاول كان يتعلق به لو
ان هذا التمرد
والانقلاب الذي كان بالضبط لو انه نجح فمن
الذي يمكن ان يسيطر على الاسلحه النوويه
الروسيه هذا الواقع
رخيبه وكبيره جدا
وان
هبوطها في حاله فوضى او هبوط روسيا في
الفوضى يخشى منه بسبب رئيسي وهو
سيطرته على الاسلحه النوويه
والقلق الثاني كان
ما الذي يحصل في روسيا
تاثيرات سيكون ذلك على مجريات الحرب
وكان من الصعب ان نرى ذلك اثناء عطله
نهايه الاسبوع كيف تكون الامور لكن القلق
الامريكي هو في الواقع يتعلق بانتقال
حول التاثيرات الفوضى على الاسلحه
التقليديه والنوويه وانتقال هذا الفوضى
الى دول البلطيق والى الاراضي التيتو نفسه
النيتو عفوا نفسها ولكن هل معنى ذلك سيد
بان الدول الحلف لم تكن قلقه كثيرا
من تداعي ذلك على دول متلاد فيها
وليتوانيا
ومجرى المعارك نفسها في في اوكرانيا
كانوا يشعرون بقلق شديد جدا ولكن تركيز
الحرب كان على منطقه
وجنوب اوكرانيا
هناك ستين كيلو متر فجوه او فراغ بين
في روسيا بيلاروسيا
ولو ان
البوليروس والروس قطعوا هذه المسافه
فان الدول البلطيق انذاك ستقطع وتبعد عن
بقيه دول الناتو ولذلك فان وسويد مهمان
جدا بالنسبه للنيتو
لانهما سيساعدان في الدفاع عن دول البلطيق
وهذا لهذا الامين العام بذل جهودا كبيرا
من اجل ضمان عضويه فنلندا والان يحاول
اقناع تركيا بان تسمح بعضويه
السويد
وهذا في غايه الاهميه وكل الامر يتعلق
بمساله الدفاع عن دول البلطيق في المقابل
الكثير من التعاليق سيد بجموف في في موسكو
تعليق الغربيه سواء على لسان مسؤولين او
على لسان عديد الصحف ركزت على ما اعتبرته
اهانه
حصلت بالنسبه لبوتين وان المكانه التي كان
يظن البعض انها له في روسيا اتضح بانها
غير صحيحه وبانه في وضع ضعيف هل هذه مسائل
تؤخذ فعلا بعين الاعتبار في روسيا
اعتقد انها هحولها المحللين مخطيون جدا او
ربما لا يفهمون ما هو الواقع الروسي او
ربما يريدون ان يصورون رغايبهم واحلامهم
في صيغه التعليقات على الاكس من ذلك روسيا
عبرت هذا الامتحان ما كانت بوتين مرموقه
بوتين مره اخرى اثبت بانه يستطيع ان يدير
الازمات وبنجاح
وهذه الازمه التي ابرت بها روسيا ايضا
اثبتت ذلك وبالتالي ايضا هناك توافقات
النخب لم تكن هناك اي خيانات داخل القياده
والسبب الرئيسي لتراجع
كان اصطدامه بالواقع المؤلم بنسبه اليه
عندما بريجوجن راى انه لا يوجد عنده اي
تاييد
في الصفوف نفسها كانت
الافراد والضباط ضد هذه المغامره وهو
تراجع والرئيس لوكا شينغ تدخل
الحل الامثل
لهذه الفتره انتقال
الى بيلاروسيا وبالتالي
سيبقى امام قوات واجنر خلود مختلفه هناك
سيناريوهات معظم مقاتله
مع وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ربما جزء منهم
يسير وراء
ينتقل الى بيلاروسيا ما يثير قلقا لديه
الغربيين وربما هناك ايضا الحديث حول نوع
من الانشطه في دول افريقيا
وكل هذا سيتبين ق من هناك سيناريوهات
مختلفه لهذا
لتطور الاحداث في الفتره القريبه ولكن
خلاصه القول
المنظومه الروسيه دوله كنظام اثبت بانه
نظام حيوي وهناك وحده في المجتمع
ولم يغدو اي شيء الذي كان قد وقفت روسيا
بخطوه واحده امام الحافه امام سيناريو
الفوضى
سيناريو كارثي وهو حرب اهليه نشوف فاحليه
لم ياخذوا ذلك بل واكثر من ذلك هذا سيكون
درسا للمستقبل الذين يفكرون باستخدام هذا
الاسلوب واللجوء الى مثل هذه الاساليب في
المستقبل ولكن عندما ننظر الى بعض
التصريحات دكتور حسن البراري في عمان يعني
مثلا عام حلف النيتو يقول
ما جرى عمق الانقسامات داخل روسيا ورئيس
الوزراء الهولندي يقول بان الكثير من
الاسئله ما زالت دون اجابات
وبلينكن يقول ربما علينا ان ننتظر اسابيع
او حتى اشهر حتى نعرف تداعيات ما جرى
بالنسبه لحلف النيتو
هل الوضع الداخلي في روسيا يهمها بهذا
الشكل
المصير الذي يجعلها قلقه جدا مما يجري في
روسيا وتداعياته على المنطقه وعلى
المستقبل
بكل نعم بكل تاكيد النيتو يعبر عن قلقه في
ما جرى بروسيا لان ذلك يعني لو تداعيات في
علاقه روسيا بشكل كامل مع النيتو ونحن
نعرف بان هناك مخاوف امنيه متبادله بين
الطرفين
وجود تصدع في القياده الروسيه ربما يشعل
حربا اهليه هكذا كانت التوقعات الاوليه
انه ربما هذا التمرد قد يقود الى حرب
اهليه وبالتالي خطر من الاسلحه النوويه
بيد من بيد اي متطرف ستقع هذه الاسلحه هذا
كان خطرا او تحديا يواجه النيتو يعني
النيتو ربما ما كان يملك الاجابه الى هذا
على هذا التحدي فبالتالي يراقب النيتو ما
يجري في روسيا لانه ايضا ذلك هذا التصدع
ان كان التصدعا حقيقيا نحن نتحدث الان عن
مظاهر الازمه في روسيا تمرد فاغنر لكن هل
هذا التمرد معزول عن اسباب جوهريه لها
علاقه ببنيه النظام لها علاقه بالفساد
الموجود في روسيا لها علاقه بعدم الرضا
عما عن الانتكاسات الاستراتيجيه او الجيو
السياسيه لروسيا بشكل عام في هذه الحرب
كيف يؤثر ذلك على الحرف في اوكرانيا كان
هذا السؤال كان هذا سؤال مطروح في اروقه
النيتو هل سيؤدي ذلك الى التصعيد اكثر هل
روسيا الجريحه هي اخطر هالبوتين الذي
يتعرض الى تقويض داخل روسيا هو اخطر على
النيتو واخطر على الامن في اوروبا
وبالتالي الاخطر على بمعنى الاخطر على
اوكرانيا فيما يتعلق بمساله التصعيد او او
خفض التصعيد كانت هذه كلها اسئله لم يكن
هناك اجابات واضحه لدنيته فبالتالي
التقييم العام اللي كان موجود عند نيتو
ودول النيتو ان ما يجري في روسيا اولا
شيئا داخلي بمعنى ان هذه الدول لن تتدخل
في مجرياته ثانيا عبروا عن قلق
ومخاوفهم الامنيات وثالثا كانوا يفكرون
دائما بانه كيف يمكن مساعده اوكرانيا
لاستثمار ما يجري في روسيا من اجل ان تحقق
مكاسب ميدانيه
تساعدها في على طاوله المفاوضات ان كان
هناك مفاوضات في قادم الايام اذا اخذنا
سناخذ تداعيات على الحرب في اوكرانيا ثم
الحرب ثم التداعيات على دول الجوار لو
بدانا بالحرب على اوكرانيا سيد
ويليامز في بروكسل هنا هناك وجهه نظر يعني
مثلا وزير الخارجيه الامريكي بلينكن قال
ما جرى سيؤثر على المردود الروسي في
اوكرانيا وسيضعفه ولكن مثلا نيويورك تايمز
تقول بالعكس شعور بوتين بانه ضعيف وبانه
اهين سيجعله شرسا اكثر في الحرب في
اوكرانيا ماذا ترجح
[موسيقى]
اعتقد ان اي الاحتمالين ممكنان نسيت بوتين
ايضا قال بان الامر سيطلب اشهر من الزمن
لفهم تبعات التاثيرات ما حصل
وانا هنا اتذكر
الرئيس اردوغان الذي هو ايضا واجه انقلاب
ضده ولكنه خرج من ذلك انقلاب اقوى من
الماضي ولانه قام بعمليات القمع
وبالتالي لو ان سيد بوتين ايضا قام
بعمليات قمع فانه ايضا سيخرج اقوى ولكن
المشكله انه يقاتل في حرب في حرب
الكثير من الناس في روسيا حسب رايي لا
يهتمون بها وليس لديهم مصلحه بها ولا يرون
انها حرب ان
يمكن ان تؤثر عليه مباشره كشعب وبالتالي
كيف يمكن للرئيس بوتين ان يعطي الطاقه
والتعبئه الجماهيريه لشعبه اذا ما اضطر ان
يعزز قواته قوته الشخصيه وسلطته الشخصيه
وبالتالي انا اعتقد نعم ستكون هذه بضعه
اشهر قلقه ومزعجه بالنسبه لروسيا ومجريات
حربها في اوكرانيا بالنسبه لاوكرانيا
تحديدا وما زلنا في هذه التداعيات سيد
بجموف جنرال بريطاني سابق كان رئيس اركان
هو ريتشارد دانيت قال في
السكاي نيوز قال انه لا يستبعد ان تشارك
فاجنر في الحرب على اوكرانيا ولكن هذه
المره من بيلاروسيا هل هذا وارد
هي وجهه النظر محترمه طبعا ولكن لا اعتقد
انا هي
ستخسر
مثل ما هو يفكر ولكن هناك نقطه اخرى مجرد
تواجد فاغنر في بيلاروس يعتبر ورقه قويه
في ايادي الرئيس سلوجاشينغا لان هناك اولا
كما تعرفون دوله اتحاد روسيا وبيلاروس
هناك مجموعه صغيره من القوات المشتركه
لهذه الدوله موجوده في اراضي بوالوس ثانيا
الان لدي
عامل الردع السلاح التكتيكي النووي الروسي
في بيلاروسيا والان اذا تواجد هناك اقول
اذا تواجد هناك
كل شيء يتوقف على عدد القوات الذي
[موسيقى]
سيكون مع
في بيلاروسيا وبالاحرى لان
سيتم حلها قوه لان معظم هذه القوه ستتراف
وزاره الدفاع لهم طلاق خيارات التاكد مع
وزاره الدفاع العوده الى منازلهم او
الذهاب مثلا الى دول الاخرى يعني يعني كل
خيارات
وقريبا نخنو سنعرف ما هو دور بريجوجن في
بيلاروسيا ولكن في هذا الظرف حاليا الرئيس
روكاشنكا عنده ورقتين قويتين في ايده وهذا
بطبيعه الحال سيكون عمل الرضا ضد اي خطه
تواصليه من قبل
الناتو ودول البلطيق ايضا لان بيلاروس
ايضا قالقه من الخطط التواصليه
وليس فقط لخلف الناتو بصوره عامه ولكن هي
الخطط التوصفيه في الدرجه الاولى
لبولندا التي تفكر في عياده اراضي بوروسيا
الغربيه التي كانت سابقا قبل الحرب
العالميه الثانيه جزءا من البولندا شانه
شان ما ياخذوا مع اوكرانيا فلذلك
اعتقد انه من اصابه تخيل ان بريجوجين
سيشاركه قريبا في العمليه في اوكرانيا
طبعا هو الزداد الضروره لا يستغنون انه
خاصه اذا ناخذ في ان الاعتبار ان هناك
ثلاث مقاطعه روسيه على حدود
اوكرانيا
الان غير محميه بصوره اعمى ولكن في هذه
الفتره القريبه اعتقد لدي الوزير الشويغو
وجراثيم وقياده الجيش كل فرص لاثبات بانه
مهمه
يستطيعون ان يتصرفون في الجبهه دون اللجوء
الى المصادر
خلال
الشهر الماضي كانوا في المخيمات ولا
تشاركوا في تصدي للهجوم الاوكرانيه المضاد
الذي بدا في اربعه من هذا الشهر يوليو
ولكن هذا لم يمنع دول الدكتور حسن البراري
بغض النظر عن اوكرانيا
بولندا وهي على الحدود الغربيه لبلاروسيا
تبدو الان حذره جدا ان لم نقل المتوجسه من
وجود مجموعه فاجنر في بيلاروسيا وهذا
دعاها الى ما سمته تقويه الجناح الشرقي
للحلف الاطلسي ما الذي يمكن ان يفعل هنا
يعني بدايه هناك قراءه لدى هذه الدول على
وجه التحديد التي كانت جزءا من منظومه
الاتحاد السوفيتي ومن حلف وارسو قبل عام
لديها وجهه نظر فيما يتعلق بمقام عروسيا
وهي تعتقد بان روسيا تريد ان تتوسع وهي
تعتقد ان ايضا جزء من النخب في هذه الدول
الثلاث يعتقد ان مجرى ايضا مسرحيه وانه
كان هو فقط توطئه لنقل هؤلاء المقاتلين من
اجل زعزعات الاوضاع في بولندا
وليتوانيا هناك هذا القلق موجود عند هذه
الدول على وجه التحديد وربما هناك ايضا في
تباين في موقف دول الناتو فيما يتعلق بهذه
القراءه لكن كل ما يمكن ان تقوم بهذه
الدول هو
يعني التوظيف هذه الفزاعه فزاعه ان هناك
خطرا قادما تهديدا كبيرا على هذا الجناح
الشرقي
والاستجابه كانت سريعه المانيا اعلنت عن
ارسال 4000 جندي ليكون في ليتوانيا هناك
ايضا مناورات عسكريه جديه اجرت في في
ليتوانيا من قبل النيتو وهناك التزام
امريكي واضح تماما بان الناتو سيدافع عن
الدول الناتو يدافع عن كل شبر عن كل
سنتيمتر يتعرض لتهديد في الماده الخامسه
من النيوتو تلزم هذه الدول على ان تدافع
عن بعضها البعض هذا هو الامن الجماعي فيما
يتعلق بدول النيتو وايضا هناك يعني مشكله
ربما غير مفهومه نحن نعرف جيدا ان روسيا
التي تريد ان تتوسع في اوكرانيا هي لا
تريد اي مواجهه مع النيتو لانها تعرف تعرف
ان مصير هذه المواجهه بالاسلحه التقليديه
ليس من صالح موسكو ولا حتى حليفاتها
بيلاروسيا يعني موازين قوى مختله بشكل
فادح لصالح دول الناتو فبالتالي الامر انا
بتقديري لغايه الان هناك يعني عدم تيقن
عند دول الناتو عن طبيعه ما جرى في روسيا
او عن طبيعه النوايا الروسيه فيما يتعلق
بهذه الدول على وجه التحديد وحتى فيما
يتعلق بالحرب على اوكرانيا هل سيتم
استثمار هذه القوات من اجل مهاجمه التي
تبعد فقط 250 كيلو متر عن حدود بيلاروسيا
ام لا نحن لا نعرف كمحللين الغرب لا يعرف
ايضا لا يستطيع ان يقرا النوايا الروسيه
لغايه هذه اللحظه لكن هذه الدول تخشى وهي
ربما اقرب الى فهم البنيه الدهنيه لدى
صناع القرار في روسيا لانه لانهم كانوا
جزءا من الاتحاد السوفيتي ويريدون ان
يحافظون على وجودهم فبالتالي يستخدموا هذه
الفزاعه او يستدعون
مساله ان التحالف هو هو ضمانه امنيه
فبالتالي على الناتو ان يعني يوسع من
وجوده في هذه المناطق هل معنى ذلك في ضوء
نتحدث فيه الان السيد نيكولاس ان الوضع
الان ازداد تعقيدا بالنسبه للفتره المقبله
كنا نتحدث عن روسيا واوكرانيا الان صرنا
نتحدث عن روسيا مع بيلاروسيا مع ليتوانيا
بولندا هل رقعه الخلاف
والمناطق الملتهبه مقبله على مزيد من
التوسع
في ان النقاط الساخنه موجوده فعلا زمن
واعتقد ان الناتو كان يعي وجودها ولكن
هناك اختلافات وتنوعات في هذه النقاط
الساخنه فكما قلت ان دخول فنلندا والسويد
الى
كان قد فكر فيه اساسا من قبل مخططي الناتو
كاحد وسائل الدفاع عن الدول البلطيق اضافه
الى
دفاعا والسويد وبالتالي
فان هذه النقطه الساخنه او هذه انتشار
النقط الساخنه هو امكانيه بان
امكانيه
لذلك منذ سنوات ولكن منذ سنوات تودون
الامور التي حصلت دون تعايا كبيره قد تقوم
بها وتكون امرا مهما هو
هو ان تزيد وتوسع دفاعاتها فهناك سلسله
كامله من الخطط العسكريه ستقدم وتعرض على
قاده النيتو للموافقه عليها ثم تطبيقها
وهذه الخطط العسكريه
فيها زياده كبيره جدا في جاهزيه واستعداد
وقدرات وزياده قدرات الدفاعيه الجماعيه
لحلف شمال الاطلس وبالتالي هذه خطوه اخرى
نحو سياده قدرات النيتو وكذلك
التركيز كما قال الامين العام للناتو
التركيز على الدفاع على كل بوصه من راضي
النيتو وهذا ليس مجرد تصريح بل هذا سيكون
عمل
ملموس
واجراءها سوف
تعاقمت فينيس وذلك لتحسين وزياده قدرات
الدفاع عن كل بوصه من اراضي النيتو هو في
هذا السياق تحديدا سيد بيجاموف الرئيس
الاوكراني زلينسكي دعا الى ما سماه توجيه
رساله تحذير واضحه الى بيلاروسيا انه اذا
مجموعه
تدخلت في ليتوانيا او في لاتفيا سيتم
القضاء عليها بالكامل ايضا المانيا قواتها
الان في ليتوانيا في حدود 850
جندي الماني هي مستعده لرفع ذلك الى 4000
هل موسكو تواجه خطرا مضاعفا عما كانت عليه
الامور في السابق
اولا من السابق لاوانه التخيل بان القوه
البيلاروسيه والقوه الروسيه في مثل هذه
الظروف السياسيه
العسكريه المؤقده ستقوم بشن هجوم على
دولتيك او بولندا لان بالفعل هناك
[موسيقى]
التفوق من حيث العدد وتقنيات لحلف الناتو
من وجهه النظر الاسلحه التقليديه فلذلك
قبل لا
تقوم روسيا
بمثل هذه بتنفيذ مثل هذه الخطوه
قبل ما تحل المشكله في اوكرانيا ولا حاليا
ولا في مستقبل لان هذا ليست رغباتها ولكن
هناك قد تكون هناك بعض الاستفزازات لان
هذه الدول وهي بدات منذ زمن بعيد في
ممارسه سياساتها معاديه لروسيا موضوع
تعزيز الجناخ العسكري في الناتو هذه
الفكره
يراوجونها في الدرجه الاولى
السياسيون في بولندا وفي دول البلطيك
والان اندمت اليهم اوكرانيا وغيرها من
الدول
وفي هذا في هذا الظرف الزمني في هذا الوضع
عندما نرى ان روسيا رجعت في بحر البلطيغ
الان روسيا تسيطر على فقط على جزء من خليج
فنلندي وهناك مقاطعه
كالينينغرات يعني الوضع عاد الا ايام
البطرس الاكبر والايام عندما روسيا حاربت
المملكه السويتيه السويديه والشقت النافذه
الى اوروبا واصبحت دوله اوروبيه واصبحت
امبراطوريه بعدما
استولت الاء هذه النافذه الى اوروبا وهي
مدينه
ووضع هناك غير مريح
ولا يوجد اي عسكري
الاستراتيجي ان يفكر في انه روسيا في هذا
التوقيت ستبدا
بمثل هذه الخطه على ذلك روسيا مهتمه الى
عوده الى عياده العلاقات مع خلف الناتو
ووجود اي توازن بين حلف الناتو وبين روسيا
كما كان عليه في عام 1997 عندما تم توقيع
له وثيقه الناتو روسيا
كل هذا المشهد الدكتور
البراري ربما دفع الى الامام بقضيه انضمام
اوكرانيا الى الحلف الاطلسي ليس بمعنى
العضويه الكامله ولكن هناك سعي يعني مثلا
هناك الان حديث عن مجلس سياسي ربما تنضم
اليه اوكرانيا قبل العضويه الكامله
وهناك حديث عن
في النهايه ستنضم ولكن على الاقل الان
هناك خطوه الى الامام في اتجاه الانضمام
الكامل لاوكرانيا هل تعتقد بان القمه
المقبله ستدفع في هذا الاتجاه
يعني ما نسمعه من تصريحات على لسان
المسؤولين في دول هامه مثل بولندا على
الاقل ان هناك سيكون محاوله حديثه من اجل
الوضع اوكرانيا على مسار الانضمام لحلف
النيتو لكن نحن ايضا نعرف بان مساله
انضمام اوكرانيا الى حلف الناتو تحتاج الى
سنوات ربط ربما تنتهي الحرب وتم التوصل
الى الاتفاق او تسويه سلميه قبل ان يتم
البحث جديا في مساله انضمام اوكرانيا لانه
هذا مسار طويل ومعقد ونحن نعرف بان الحلف
ايضا لا يضم اي دوله ان كان هناك جزءا
منها محتل فاوكرانيا وفقا لموقف دول
الناتو لديها جزء كبير جدا منها او ربما
20% من مساحتها تقع تحت الاحتلال الروسي
حاليا فبالتالي مساله الانضمام هي مساله
معقده مركبه لكن اعتقد ان الاقرب ان هذه
المحاولات السياسيه التي تجري الان هي
ربما لرفع معنويات الاوكران في مقاومه
الاحتلال الروسي هي ايضا للتاكيد على وقوف
دول النيتو مع اوكرانيا او بامن اوكرانيا
من خلال المساعدات العسكريه والاقتصاديه
وان هذا سيفتح الباب امام المزيد من
المساعدات ويبعث برساله واضحه الى القياده
الروسيه بان دول الناتو ملتزمه بمساعده
اوكرانيا حتى النهايه وما سمعناه اليوم
على لسان
المستشار الالماني هو يصب في في نفس
الاتجاه يقول بان المانيا مستعده لحرب
طويله او مساعده اوكرانيا في حرب طويله
واضح تماما بانه يعني اذا كان هناك ما
يسمى بتوازن الاراده في البدايه كان لصالح
روسيا لانه كان هناك اسرار على بدء هذه
الحرب يبدو الان ان الميل للجهه الغربيه
للغرب زائد اوكرانيا التي لديها الاراده
الاكثر على ان تستمر هذه المعركه حتى يتم
تحرير هذه الاراضي او حتى يتم تحسين شروط
التفاوض بالنسبه للاوكران فالمساله هي انا
بتقدير معقده لكن اصوات كثيره بدات تطل
علينا ونسمعها في الغرب تدعو الى انضمام
اوكرانيا او وضع اوكرانيا على سكه
الانضمام خلال عقد من الزمن هل هذا يمكن
ان يؤدي سيد ويليامز الى مزيد استفزاز
روسيا في هذه المواجهه تتحدث عن
225 الف جندي روسي قتلوا هل هناك خوف من
ان روسيا التي الان قد تبدو جريحه ليس فقط
بسبب ما يجري في اوكرانيا وانما ايضا بسبب
ما جرى مع فاجنر ربما تستفز اكثر من
اللازم وبالتالي هناك
نتائج قد لا تكون سهله في المستقبل
اعتقد اننا تجاوزنا نقطه
السماعه ما تفكر به موسكو ان روسيا
دوله معتديه بمجباح او حسب ما ترى النيتو
او بموجب ما تقوم به من اعمال فقد هاجمت
اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
وثمه اصوات قليله في النيتو
تتعاطف
بحيث انها تهد ان تجري حوار مع روسيا
ضيفكم من موسكو كان محقا بالاشاره الى
1900 وثيقه 1997 التي وقعت النيتو مع
روسيا في عمل شراكه وصداقه
هذه الوثيقه لم تذكر اطلاقا في الاخبار
سابقا لانها تعتبر
انها نتيجه اوقات مثاليه اوقات مثاليه
والتفاعليه فمنذ عام 1997
عدد
الدول الاعضاء جدا خاصه في اوروبا الشرقيه
هذه الدول انت غيرت التوازن في النيتو
وغير لا تقبل ان تخضع لتخويف او تهديد او
خوف من قبل روسيا
هم
مصرون على ان النيتو ينبغي ان تساعد تدافع
عنهم ليس بالحديث مع روسيا انما
ببناء
الدفاع الدفاعات جيده كما كان الوضع اثناء
الحرب البارده
خط يمرك عبره كله اوروبا
كثيرون السيد في موسكو يتحدثون على الاقل
في الاعلام الغربي للتوضيح يتحدثون عما
يسمونه اخفاق استراتيجي لبوتين في حربه في
اوكرانيا هذا التعبير قالها حتى اكثر من
مسؤول امريكي ومسؤول في الحلف الاطلسي هل
هناك ايه امكانيه لمراجعه موسكو لحساباتها
في ضوء ما جرى في اوكرانيا من اخفاقات
عسكريه مع فاجنر مع ازدياد ربما شراسه بين
قوسين حلف الاطلسي وسعي الى تقويه مزيد من
الدول على الحدود مع روسيا وبيلاروسيا
ايضا
السؤال الوجيه واولا يجب القول انه
يجب النظر الى الاسباب الموضوعيه التي ادت
الى هذا الصراع والى اتخاذ روسيا مثل هذه
القرار
القرار لم كانت روسيا تخوده لو لم تغيرت
الامور في اوكرانيا بعد 2014 الانقلاب في
كيه فهما فهما توسع خلف الناتو وانتم
تعرفون جيدا
انه كانت هناك مطالبه الروسيه بالوضع
الوثائق الامنيه مع الولايات المتحده مع
حلف الناتو وباطنه هناك كانت المشكله
الداخليه في اوكرانيا اوكرانيا لا تسيطر
على بعض المناطق فيها منذ هذا الانقلاب
2014 القرم خرجت من اوكرانيا اختارت
العوده الى روسيا ايضا كانت المشكله بين
السلطه في كييف
وجمهوريات
دونيسكو لوغانسك لم يتم حل هذه المشكله
على رغم من السائق روسيا في اطار صيغه
نورماندي الا عوده هذه
الاقاليم
عرض الى الى الفضاء القانوني الاوكراني
وتسويه الامور لان في موسكو كانت هناك وما
تزال حتى
اليوم هناك الاطراف التي كانت تسعى
لتسويه الامور بطرق سلميه والحفاظ على
اوكرانيا
كدوله محايده لروسيا لا تشكل تحديثا ولكن
انتم تعرفون كانت هناك خطوط التهديد
بالبدي بعمليه خاطفه اوكرانيا في
دنيسكو دونيت طلبت مصادر من روسيا ولم يكن
لدي الرئيس الروسي بعد الرفض حلف الناتو
وبعد رفض اداره بايدن
التوقيع للوثائق
لم يكن خيار اخر غير بذات هذه الحرب هذا
اولا ثانيا من الصعب التخيل ان الرئيس
بوتين والقياده روسيه لم تكن لديهم خطوه
خطه كانت موجوده فلذلك بعدما كانت هناك
بعض الاخطاء وفي هذه العمليه الخاصه خاصه
في الجبهه الدبلوماسيه عندما توافقت روسيا
على مسوده الاتفاقيه في اسطنبول بادين
اغلقتها
اوكرانيا بعدما وقع رئيس الوفد الاوكراني
بالاحرف الاولى لهذه الاتفاقيه ولكن روس
اخذوه وانسحبوا من دواخل هذا كان قبل
هو مواصله العمليه كالعاده نريد ان نقوم
في نهايه هذه الحلقه بجوله السؤال فيها هو
كيف ترى سيناريوهات المواجهه مستقبلا بين
روسيا وحلف الاطلسي خاصه في ضوء القمه
المرتقبه سنبدا بالسيد ويليامز نعود للسيد
بيجاموف مره اخرى ثم ننهي بالدكتور حسن
البراري اذا السيد ما هي السيناريوهات
التي تراها
اعتقد ان الامر كله يعتمد على ما الذي
سيحصل في ساحات المعارك فلو ان اوكرانيا
استطاعت ان تخترق
وتقطع
نصف الوجود العسكري الروسي في جنوبها
اوكرانيا
فان موقف اوكراني انذاك سيتعزز وموقف
الغرب
لغرض
التوسط
في التوصل لحال ايضا سيتعزز هذا الموقف
ولكنني اخشى انه رغم ذلك
ان الاختراق هذا اذا ما تحقق فلن يتحقق
قريبا
وبالتالي
السيناريو الذي اعتقده الاكثر احتمالا
هو تكون حاله ركود وجمود
وحتى وصول الى حرب مجان مجمده او وقف
اطلاق نار دون اي اتفاق حوله
وبقدر التعلق الامر
وروسيا فكما قلت
النيتو
سيعززون الدفاعاتهم
هناك ايدي او اي اتفاق مع روسيا طالما
انها تستمر في احتلال اوكرانيا او اجزاء
من اوكرانيا سيد بيجاموف
اولا المعركه في اوكرانيا ستستمر الغرب
ستدعم اوكرانيا
بكل قواتهم
لن يتم قبول اوكرانيا قريبا في حلف الناتو
ربما سيتم اختراع صيغه
على شكل مثلا مجلس روسيا خلف سيكون مجلس
سحلف الناتو
واوكرانيا ولكن حلف الناتو لا يريدوا الان
ليس في مصلحته الدخول في صراع المباشر مع
روسيا ما دام هناك القوه الاوكرانيه التي
في الجبهه وكل شيء سيتوقف على هذه المعارك
في يوليو
وسيتم خصم هذه الموقف
قريبا
وربما حتى اكتوبر
وستستمر هذه حرب الاستنزاف لا اعتقد ان حل
التجميد تجميد هو امثل الحلول لان هذه
الازمه جذورها كانت عميقه وهي اسباب
متعدده ويجب ان يكون حل هذه المشكله ايضا
يكون حلا وليس الحرب بين روسيا واوكرانيا
بين موسكو وكيف ولكن هو الحل يجب ايجاد
الحل بين القطب الروسي والقطبه الغربي
برئاسه الولايات المتحده وانجلترا دكتور
براري
يعني انا اميل الى ان الامر يعتمد على
مدى التزام دول الناتو بامداد اوكرانيا
بالسلاح واي نوع من السلاح بمعنى اذا تم
الاستجابه للطلب اوكرانيا في تزويدها
بطائرات الاف 16 فان هذا سيساعد الهجوم
المضاد على تحقيق اختراق يعزز من الاوراق
التفاوضيه بيد كيف ويضعف من القوات
الروسيه ويضعف ايضا من موقف بوتين داخليا
لكن ان استمرت تزويد السلاح بهذه الطريقه
انا اميل الى سيناريو الجمود المؤلم
للطرفين واستمرار الاستنزاف الى ان
يتوصلوا الى نوع من الهدنه وليس حلا
سياسيا بالمعنى الشامل فبالتالي هي بتقدير
ازمه مفتوحه
السيناريو القادم يعني يعتمد بشكل كبير
جدا على مسالتين الاولى هو مدى التزام
الغرب في تزويد السلاح واي نوع من السلاح
والثانيين تماسك الجبهه الداخليه في روسيا
لانه ما جرى من تمرد في فاغنر انا بتقديره
هو مظهر لازمه داخليه روسيا لتصدع في
النخبه الحاكمه هو هو السؤال الصعب
بالنسبه لبوتين يعني ربما ياتي الوقت
قريبا عندما يسال المجتمع الروسي الذي
تغيب اخباره عن الاعلان بسبب حاله من
الاستبداد والقبضه الامنيه سيسال سؤال
الصعب لماذا ذهبنا الى اوكرانيا ماذا
حققنا وما هو الثمن فبالتالي مجمل هذه
الامور ربما تؤدي الى الى الى الى مسار
لن يكون في صالح بوت في نهايه الامر شكرا
جزيلا لك الدكتور حسن البراري من عمان
شكرا ايضا لضيفنا من موسكو رولاند بيجاموف
ولضيفنا من بروكسل نيكولاس
كالعاده ننتقل الى تغريدات لبعض المسؤولين
السياسيين حول موضوع هذه الحلقه ونبدا
بهذه التغريده لرئيسي ليتوانيا غناس
لوسيدا ويقول فيها مع نقل قياده فاغنر
ونشر اسلحه النوويه تكتيكيه في بيلاروسيا
نواجه وضعا امنيا جديدا في المنطقه في قمه
بيلينيوس نحتاج الى اتخاذ قرارات سريعه
لرفع مستوى الرذا والدفاع الامامي للجناح
الشرقي لحلف النيتو
وزير الدفاع الليتواني
اربداس انوشوسكاس تحدث عن تقديم المزيد من
الدعم الى اوكرانيا قائلا استجابه لطلب
اوكرانيا للمساعده في تعزيز الدفاعاتها
الجويه لتوانيا تشتري منظومتي صواريخ
متقدمه من نوع نسمس للجيش الاوكراني
وستسلمها الى اوكرانيا في غضون ثلاثه اشهر
الرئيس الاوكراني زيلينسكي اثنى على الدعم
المعنوي والعسكري المقدم لبلاده وذلك
بالقول زياره رئيسي بولندا وليتوانيا
لبلدنا تاكيد اخر للدعم القوي في الوقت
المناسب خاصه عشيه قمه النيتو فيلا نيس
ممتن لقياده الرئيس الفولندي في انشاء
ائتلاف دبابات والمشاركه النشطه في تحالف
المقاتلين الشكر ايضا لليتوانيا على قرار
شراء منظومتي صواريخ نرويجيه متقدمه
لنقلها الى اوكرانيا شكرا للاصدقاء
الحقيقيين لاوكرانيا لزيارتهم معا بتحقيق
النصر
ونختم بهذه التغريده لرئيسه وزراء استونيا
كايا كلس جاء فيها يتطلب الواقع الامنيه
الجديد حلولا جديدا يحتاج الدفاع الاوروبي
الى قوه دفع حاسما نحن بحاجه الى قوه ردع
موثوقه بما فيه الكفايه لوقف العدوان
الروسي وتجنب الحرب
نبني اوروبا ذات فعاليه قتاليه قادره على
توفير الامن عبر المحيط الاطلسي
بهذا مشاهدينا الكرام نكون قد وصلنا الى
نهايه حلقه هذا الاسبوع برنامج سيناريوهات
طوال شهر يوليو تموز المقبل سيتناول قضايا
هامه ربما لم تاخذ نصيبها الوافر في زحمه
الاخبار سنتوقف طوال شهر يوليو مع مواضيع
مهمه
يقع الاشاره اليها في الاخبار ولكن تحتاج
الى وقف التامل وتحليل سنتناول الذكاء
الاصطناعي سنتناول الفساد تتناول الطاقه
المتجدده وكذلك التغيرات المناخيه اربع
حلقات طوال شهر يوليو تموز تتناول كل هذه
القضايا وقفه معها لانها ربما ربما لم
تاخذ نصيبها بالكامل في زحمه الاخبار
والتطورات السياسيه دمتم في رعايه الله
والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]